pas cueillir notre champion du monde un
garçon que j'aime énormément qui est
avec nous ce soir
blaise matuidi et nos traditions
[Applaudissements]
je
thury majimaji la braise d'être
remerciés d'être là la cible est si vous
dites je devrais dire qu'on va dire un
petit truc sur blaise d'abord c'est que
c'est un mec d'une humilité c'est un
truc de fou
voilà c'est pour ça c'est ça que j'aime
chez toi tu la ramènes jamais c'est pour
ça que c'est un très très grand
footballeur et ça fait des semaines
qu'on en parle tous les deux parce que
tu viens tu m'as dit je viendrai
vraiment si je vais un jour faire des
missions c'est pour mon association et
je voulais absolument que tu viennes et
c'est vrai que c'est une association
pour laquelle tu donnes avec toute la
famille depuis des années et franchement
je trouve que c'est un garçon un mois
exceptionnel à la fois je suis allé
dîner avec lui je dis la vérité et
blaise il et j'ai pas deux comme lui
demandent des photos il ya fait des
fauteuils tout le monde y parle à tout
le monde il est tranquille avant les
mecs qui disent aimer c'est pas moi
blaise matuidi la victoire soit qu'il
est sympa sur son visage lagardère est
franchement je souhaite vous êtes déjà
de féliciter pour ta carrière c'était
une carrière exceptionnelle jugé perdu
beaucoup d'argent parce que j'avais dit
que la juventus gagnerait la ligue des
champions que ça l'année prochaine voilà
ça c'est sûr et juste dire un mot et je
voudrais dire que tu es un mec
exceptionnel je suis très heureux de
tabor
[Applaudissements]
il ya trois ans tu as créé l'association
l'association définit comme facilitateur
de projets envers les jeunes à travers
de nombreuses collaborations associative
mais également plusieurs temps fort
annuel qui permettent d'entreprendre de
grandes actions dont la construction
d'un orphelinat au congo on va regarder
la présentation de l'association et
après bien sûr on va faire plein de
trucs avec toi parce qu'on a envie de
t&d sur l'association et on a envie d'en
savoir encore plus sur toi d'ailleurs je
t'ai fait un petit truc sur tellouck
stuart a changé beaucoup de bouquins
c'est comme moi un moment tu te chercher
un moment tu te chercher je sais pas moi
moi je me suis pas encore prouvé j'ai un
enfant d'origine
voilà d'angola et du congo donc mes
parents bien sûr sont nés là-bas avait
fait un passage au congo on a vu les
conditions dans laquelle ses enfants
vivait était assez triste on va dire et
et on sait très bien que ça remplacera
pas tout mais si ça peut faire qui
puisse avoir au moins le sourire
ben ça c'est c'est le but de notre
action
les adore les enfants il a gardé
toujours dans ce groupe a dans son coin
de la tête son enfance sa sensibilité
concernant les pratiques des enfants
viennent delà de sa propre expérience
aussi peut donner souvent vraiment s'il
donne le sourire est ravi que s'amuser
avec eux rire avec
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
on a préparé une petite cerise regarde
de thé look alors déjà on commence quand
tu étais en font regarder
blaise matuidi enfants regarder basse et
il faut des frises et merci ouais ça
avait l'air vénère la faire voir l'union
j'adorais de l'est là je crois que à mes
frères moi même pas apporté de l'entente
volley ball et longtemps longtemps le
vin kinder ou quoi frérot là après alors
en 2004 tu as commencé ta carrière
trouve pas mal mais ta tête tu as changé
je trouve ta pas la même tâche ouais
mais attention il n'est pas n est pas
mal j'ai mal et choula il alors eh bien
alors c'est pas mal même la tenue et
tous y avait 17 ans la place 17 ans
trois ans plus tard en 2007 tu joues
pour l' as st-etienne aaa
frérot la la peau qu'on va sans parler
tout je connais ça tu as voulu faire des
pics tu vois que je veux un truc des
structures il m'a dit fais moi inculpé
structurée mais tu as toujours la même
tête mais là elle a pou lé thème des
trois visages et bien oui bah oui mais
c'est le même cas d'ophélie winter s'est
pour sa part est d'accord la connaît sa
tétine un peu bas à saint-etienne il n'y
a pas de professeur pas évident pour moi
merci jean michel jarre qui a fait une
bonne pour les plus 170 maintenant en
2014 était désormais au pays
[Applaudissements]
j'adore avec la des sublimes 0 et j'aime
beaucoup cela
est-ce qu'on repartirait pas sur sa fair
ou alors je t'aime beaucoup comme ça
mais j'aime bien les traits circulaire
ouais ouais c'est pas mal ça et le petit
col roulé rouge magnifique j'aime
beaucoup
alors on termine avec une dernière photo
non juillet 2018 tu es donc sacré
champion du monde tu es à la food and
his way
voilà c'est non c'est non du budget doit
savoir que j'ai perdu un pari mois son
père tous les jours non mais tu as tu
qui fêtera sempé non à c'était c'était
quoi c'est vrai c'est avec la couleur
est pas ou pas voilà je veux isabelle
sûreté menées ainsi rehaussées rue
oui mais non j'ai mené la photo
précédente à la forme du crâne
cette photo merci bas march é té sympa
ton équipe de foot quand tu étais petit
regarder quand vous l'avez prouvé
même la même page tu as la même tête ont
fait un truc de ouf ça ne va pas changer
je te jure 5 mai blesse c'est parce
qu'il a l'air toujours gentil oui les
terres inertes
c'est pour ça qu'il est bon au foot
parce que tu te dis oui ça va il est
gentil carrière l'hiver vous retire
l'énergie pour l' égard l'énergie pour
le terrain je te jure que c'est vrai
alors blazy un petit truc aussi
j'aimerais revenir sur ton ça fait
longtemps que je tenais plus un coeur à
prendre
tu étais même mariés pour camer de
mariage tu as fait un truc incroyable
c'est en 2016 ttout grand rex avec
t'accompagner pour aller voir star wars
et pendant les bandes-annonces y ait eu
un film qui a été diffusée qui se
terminait avec un message de vos filles
qui demandait à ta femme de l'époque
normand énorme
franchement ces formes franchement
frérot et ses minous fois qu elle dit
des tu t'es dit je veux faire un délire
comme ça ouais je me suis je fais un
délire c'est toi t'as romantique pas sa
joie c'est vrai qu'à style c'est moins
cher il appelle entre deux pubs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors venez en 87 à tous
il paraît que tu as 25 100 toulousain de
ouf au début par équipe faisait chambrer
grave par les autres joueurs je disais
du ping à ses études et du fait
maintenant à prêter passe à paris
d'après l'accent parisien ma tante à
l'accent italien fais ça tu t'adaptes on
s'adapte tu t'adaptes toujours ouais tu
vas pas arrêter tout de suite tu vas
rien combien de temps encore tuer encore
5 5 6 ans j'espère j'espère voir comment
tu coures frérot tu peux me faire peur
comme federer 38 39 ans je le dirai
jamais si tu peux un peu je suis dans un
club qui me donne la possibilité
justement de pouvoir aller encore plus
loin donc on verra bien être a fait plus
de 670 match bon tu as fait quatre clubs
dont et accroît au début après
saint-etienne à paris saint germain et
la juve est heureux voilà donc c'est
vrai que 56 buts en carrière
vraiment je te dis tu nous avais
l'allèle ça c'est le plus beau souvenir
que tu es la coupe du monde fina s'est
bien sûr c'est le plus beau souvenir de
gagner une coupe du monde c'est un rêve
de gosse et même étant en étant petit
j'aurais jamais honnêtement imaginé être
parmi ces 23 ac ou fait ce magnifique
trophée ça a était vraiment un moment un
moment magique qui restera dans le coeur
des français
et d'ailleurs vous avez reçu la légion
d'honneur il ya quelques jours ce qu'est
le 4 juin dernier en compagnie des 22
autres champions du monde devra revoir
ce moment tu va nous raconter comment tu
t'es senti regarde
monsieur blaise matuidi au nom de la
république française
nous vous faisons chevalier de la légion
d'honneur
[Applaudissements]
c'était un grand moment d'émotion ça ou
parce que tu étais fier d'avoir la
légion d'honneur ton père tu es parents
il est comme des fous
je pense que pour moi la plus grande
fierté vient de départ en vrai c'est ça
voilà c'est c'est leur faire honneur
pour moi c'est ma plus grande réussite
on va dire moi c'est que tu es champion
du monde mon frère et toi tu es tout
calme moi je suis champion de rien mais
moi je suis champion du monde mais c'est
encore gratos et toi tu as la peau on
al'impression lution connu on y sent bal
avec total mon frère c'est un truc tout
franchement tu as toujours été comme ça
t'es tu restes calme ag des moments de
folie que tu vas faire après la coupe du
monde tu vas faire quand on a gagné la
coupe du monde c'est comme benhaim côté
réussi à brushing qui tu veux tu vas
fermer des lits il est calme il est
tranquille alors il y en a deux que un
petit fou rire pendant la légion
d'honneur
c'est paul pogba et adil rami voilà
regarde les deux paul pogba sans doute
le joueur le plus taciturne calme posé
de l'équipe
[Applaudissements]
alors et on a trouvé une vidéo qui vient
d'un ancien coéquipier du psg c'est
notre pote mamadou sakho qui te croiser
en pleine rue et ils t'appellent est ton
regard va changer directement quand tu
le reconnais regarde très peu de cette
vidéo pas ouais de fou paris c'est petit
regardez qui je croise mon garçon
[Applaudissements]
profiter de sa présence juste pour dire
un truc parce que dans toute la presse
people je sais pas si ça vous agace ou
pas on lit tout le temps pas forcément
ribéry qui mangent aztèques en or les
voitures des footballeurs et tout en
revanche je lis jamais kanaky et qui
sont voilà qu'ils héritent des
associations comme vous ou que tu es
moins de trucs fonds alloués à me
répéter mais qui donne ton argent
effectivement et ça ça on le lit partout
est ce que ça vous agace pas ce côté on
sort toujours que les mots balle
l'économie le côté bling-bling des
footballeurs et on dit pas tout ce que
vous donnez aussi aux autres comme moi
je passe deux mois j'ignorais
aujourd'hui cette association que vous
que vous dirigez après c'est vrai que à
ce niveau là on est assez discret on n'a
pas envie non plus tout le temps de
montrer que on en est de voila je pense
que c'est pour nous le plus important
c'est ce que l'on fait ce que l'on donne
c'est pas ce qui ressort voilà pour nous
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui importe après
on vous laisse là préjugés j'ai pas
envie de bien sûr parler de ça mais
après c'est vrai quoi la presse après
c'est vrai que nous voilà il ya des
émissions télé dans lesquelles nous
parle mais c'est vrai que blaise
il est très très présent sur son
association et lui c'est vraiment sa
priorité reste correct avait 12 sur nous
alors je voudrais comprendre question
alors je crois savoir assez parce que
c'est par rapport à ton jeu à mon avis
la pieuvre le céreq tête partout sur le
terrain on croit toujours qu'il y ait
plusieurs sans rigoler c'est un truc de
ouf et le chewing gum parce que tu
lâches pas les mecs c'est ça c'est ça
ouais tu lâches pas à l'entraînement
j'étais away j'étais chance et c'est
samir nasri qui m'avait donné ce surnom
le chewing gum atentat les coincés dans
leur classe et une tanit et servir quand
on t'a sur le dos tu dis que tu vas tu
veux tu vas te mettre sur ce gala t il
était sûr que c'est une tannée pour lui
à le pain et les pâtes gratuit ah ouais
mais tu te bats à fond sur le terrain je
vois tu donnes tout à chaque match on
dirait que c'est le dernier frère tu
mens jouer doute quand même dingue haute
marne
après je joue avec mes qualités ouais
mais quels étaient ses sa c2 pas lâcher
ses skis et c'est ce qui m'a amené à
m'amener ici
alors il ya la coupe du monde féminine
en ce moment la france a gagné encore
hier ont failli on est en huitièmes de
finale à paris y est c'est fait as tu
regarde un peu ce que font les
françaises avec bien sûr bien sûr un peu
ce le football féminin est il évolue à
vitesse grand v on est on est vraiment
contents non tant que joueur de l'équipe
de france et je pense que même les
français sont contents c'est ouf avoir
atteint 9,4 ça y est ce que 10 millions
un record en record historique pour un
match de coupe du monde féminine et
canal+ aussi a très bien marché hier
près d'un million de téléspectateurs
aussi sur canal+ donc c'est absolument
énorme souligne die en arrière je t'ai
9,4 avec quatre russes et 10 millions 3
en tout c'est exceptionnel vous avez un
petit récap regarder de ce qui se passe
sur la coupe du monde féminine
le 7 juin dernier le match france corée
du sud en direct du stade de france
donné le coup d'envoi de cette coupe du
monde féminine
un match remporté haut la main par les
françaises 4 l'ua 098 millions de
supporters avaient répondu présent au
rendez-vous de ce tout premier match
soit 44 % du public
des scores extrêmement haut qui ont été
confirmées avec le deuxième match des
bleus jouaient hier soir à nice les
joueuses affronter cette fois ci la
norvège qui s'est incliné 2 buts à 1
[Applaudissements]
ou encore l'audience a été au rendez
vous avec 9,4 millions de supporters
et suit les matchs de foot féminine 3
hier parce que c'est wendy renard qui
marque contre son camp
on va tendre et wendy renard elle est
normale a dit je vais faire le zapping
j'adore j'adore